one las vegas business owner born in
ukraine is doing her part to help her
homeland and truly remarkable she's
sending all of the profits from her
online business to her home country our
mary jane bellies joining us live at our
lady of las vegas church it's on rancho
and alta with the details this
business owner quite the endeavor
yeah heather good morning irina
kaganovsky is the ceo of freedom a
wellness beauty line and she says her
company freedom is a reflection of what
the people in ukraine are fighting for
now irina was born in ukraine while it
was still under soviet rule and she says
she is heartbroken to hear what is
happening in her home country that's why
she's donating all the profits from her
business to help the people of ukraine
she says right now ukrainian refugees
lack basic necessities like hygiene care
products and she's also planning to send
sanitation items back home
we're taking our profits and we're
sending essentials because we own i own
an everyday you know
wellness line right so we have a ton of
stuff from wipes that we did for alaska
airlines and for the sands hotel
actually too
and we have a lot of that extra stuff
that this is people people need this
stuff right now they don't have showers
they can't get clean i mean
they're freezing and
everything we can do to help so we've
got some deodorants we've got some wipes
irina says she will continue to send
supplies this week and will continue
sending supplies for as long as she can
and many others in our community are
also helping out this includes a
ukrainian prayer event here at our lady
of las vegas church for this weekend and
coming up in our next half hour we'll
tell you how you can get involved if you
would like to help out as well reporting
live from alta and rancho mary jane
balleza live local now